bonjour nous sommes jeudi 2 juillet
merci de nous retrouver pour ce nouveau
numéro de file echo votre magazine
d'actualité qui revient sur l'économie
locale on commence au site avec les
titres de cette édition l'alstom open de
france commence aujourd'hui au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
un événement sportif majeur qui a des
conséquences sur l'économie du
territoire
nous en parlerons des twin est une
société fondée par deux yvelinois ils
produisent des vêtements de sport
inspiré du dessin animé olive et tom
ils ont surtout inventé le football un
nouveau concept sportif
enfin avec les grosses chaleurs cette
semaine nous vous font découvrir une
entreprise qui va vous donner envie
direction les coulisses de la société
albert elle attrape célèbre pour ses
glaces est aussi dans notre entretien de
cette semaine nous allons parler sport
en entreprise pour motivée et soudée les
salariés nous sommes ce soir en plateau
avec guillaume 09 non soir en soie et
sébastien vous vous êtes tous les deux
fondateurs et associés de touche et de
tâches events vous êtes sinon pour nous
parler de votre société de
l'événementiel et du sport en entreprise
qui prend de plus en plus de place nous
y reviendrons dans quelques instants
avant cela passe en revue l'actualité la
semaine
et ce jeudi 2 juillet c'est l'ouverture
de la 99e édition de l'alstom open de
france au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le plus grand
événement golfique en france entre les
greens un village d'entreprises est
installée jusqu'à dimanche
au total une cinquantaine d'entreprises
sont présents sur des stands pendant les
quatre jours de compétition et près de
60000 visiteurs curieux vont s'y
promener nous avons cherché à connaître
les retombées économiques de cet
événement sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines sur place michael me
d'euros et william l l'open de france de
golf est une compétition sportive
mondialement connue mais le tournoi est
également de vitrine commerciale pour de
nombreuses marques pendant quatre jours
un village entreprises s'est installée
entre les greens et stands coûte entre
3000 et 5000 euros
un investissement qui ne décourage pas
les sociétés il ya effectivement la
notoriété est présent parce qu'il ya
cinquante mille personnes qui viennent
sur l'open c'est un coeur de cible c'est
simple une personne mais c'est sain
camping golfeur donc c'est clairement un
coeur de cible pour elle et tous les ans
elle rencontre les pratiquants de golf
et elle fonda vente aussi il ya de la
vente qui est possible sur place donc
voilà il ya le l'image la notoriété la
vente et une dernière chose qui est
importante c'est aussi le côté be to be
l'open c'est aussi un événement
on invite ses clients privilégiés ses
prestataires donc c'est là aussi les
directeurs de golf pour les réseaux
c'est là aussi qu'on rencontre un peu
les contacts importants 10 to be donc
voilà il ya ces trois impacts et
retombées importantes pour les exposants
55 exposants sont présents cette année
les 60000 spectateurs peuvent acheter
des souvenirs dans la boutique du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour l'entreprise la compétition permet
de booster leur chiffre d'affaires on
peut pas parler de chiffres
précisément mais nous on assure grâce à
l'open de france à peu près un quart ou
un tiers de notre chiffre d'affaires de
l'année donc c'est quand même c'est
quand même un événement très important
pour nous pour notre résultat de l'année
donc
donc voilà on met tous les moyens en
oeuvre pour pouvoir accéder aux
résultats
pour réserver une tente les entreprises
font leur demande dès novembre pour
cette 99e édition le village
d'entreprises affichent complet un
projet d'expansion est à l'étude pour
surfer sur le succès commercial de
l'open
on va réfléchir dès cette année pour
voir comment on peut agrandir village
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez vu on a
une forme un peu en carrés avec des
tentes au milieu
donc si on veut de nouveaux espaces il
faut qu'on trouve un peu de place
ailleurs donc reculer un peu sur la zone
vip on va on va réfléchir mais
effectivement ce serait bien de trouver
pousser un peu les murs pour les
prochaines chaque année 80 % les
entreprises renouvellent leur
partenariat avec le village de l'open de
france de golf
il s'appelle david jong il a gagné la
bfm business academy le concours des
créateurs d'entreprise diffusée à la
radio et à la télévision
david on y est né à guyancourt il a
remporté cette dixième édition face à 15
autres candidats se retape sa start up
française sprint à une coque polaroïd
nouvelle génération capables d'imprimer
une photo instantanée ans à partir d'un
smartphone la start up est basé entre
paris et les états unis
elle a déjà levé plus d'un million et
demi de dollars de fonds et pour la
suite les fameuses coque polaroïd
devrait être commercialisé d'ici
novembre 2015 et david yang était
également présent sur paris saclay une
veste cet événement se déroulait
mercredi 1er juillet à l'université de
paris saclay il a mis les entrepreneurs
évinois à l'honneur pour cette cinquième
édition
dix projets innovants ont été mis en
lumière le but pour ces jeunes
entrepreneurs présence était de
présenter leur projet de se faire
connaître et aussi pourquoi pas
d'attirer l'oeil des investisseurs
écoutez bruno duval président finances
et technologique par sa cage il ya un
dynamisme créé un créatif sur le plateau
qui se développe qui n'est pas nouveau
ce que nous on fait ça depuis 15 ans ici
sur le plateau
donc c'est pas quelque chose de neuf
mais c'est quelque chose qui prend de la
vitesse donc
on le voit aujourd'hui on le voit on
fait deux événements donc on est on
s'inscrit bien dans cette prise de
vitesse qui ce qui se déroule donc on
est effectivement sur cette dynamique là
les éléments et la qualité des projets
également augmenté vers que c'est très
surprenant
on est les premiers surpris on devrait
pas l'être mais on est les premiers
surpris voire une qualité des projets
qui augmentent et nous allons parler
maintenant voiture l'agglomération de
rambouillet ces types en voiture
électrique à quatre modèles de f city
ces voitures en kit connectés réalisé
par la société kraft france sont mises à
disposition des 25 communes et des
associations de l'agglomération en
britten une acquisition de plus de 50000
euros soit 13 mille euros par voiture
l'objectif est donc de tester ces
véhicules avant d'agrandir la flotte et
de donner l'exemple pour passer à la
mobilité électrique en sept ans une
prochaine étape dans ce dispositif
mobilité sera mené des bornes devraient
être installés pour des voitures qui se
conduisent seul sans chauffeur sur le
territoire de rambouillet et un grand
groupe de cosmétiques a organisé pour la
sixième année une journée de solidarité
annuel baptisé citizen des ces deux
journées des pouilles dans 62 pays en
france cette année 192 actions sont
proposées dont une ce jeudi au jardin de
cocagne à magny les hameaux l'occasion
de permettre aux salariés de tisser et
d'améliorer des liens entre catherine
mulato et patrie j'ai donné qu'ils
mènent dans la vie professionnelle
ironique et technicienne de recherche là
elle a troqué la blouse blanche pour une
tenue plus sportive
on la retrouve en train de cueillir des
cocos plat cela fait cinq ans que cet
amour pas yens participent au sit-in
anglais une journée pour les autres j'ai
déjà deux fois travailler avec des
enfants handicapés
ça permet de voir effectivement d'autres
choses quoi d'ouvrir son esprit à
d'autres à d'autres domaines également
oui je suis au laboratoire derrière une
haute avec des gants une blouse blanche
je me couche ça change puis la sfef et
une journée au grand air sympa aussi
c'est très bien mais sauf que le clip il
ne doit pas bouger ton qui est chef de
culture au jardin de cocagne à magny les
hameaux une association d'insertion ou
jeu
lui il donne des conseils à deux
managers de la marque véronique et katia
c'est un travail d'équipé là on est tous
au même niveau et on travaille tous
ensemble je pense que les histoires de
hiérarchie rentrent pas en ligne de
compte et c'est l'occasion aussi
d'écouter et de d'être au service des
autres et de
d'écouter ce qu'on a à faire et de de
recevoir aussi ceux qui transmettent le
savoir aux salariés et ça ainsi un rôle
inversé pour eux c'est super il adore ça
les jardins de cocagne reçoivent
régulièrement des salariés de grands
groupes pour partager une journée en
immersion
le groupe l'oréal y participe depuis six
ans avec l'association unis cité cette
année le nombre de collaborateurs
inscrits a été battu le nombre de
collaborateurs ne fait qu'augmenter
d'année en année parce que ils se
rendent compte que c'est non seulement
un moyen pour les collaborateurs de se
rendre utile dans des associations de
sortir du cadre de travail et c'est
aussi un moyen entre des collaborateurs
de se rencontrer
donc c'est aussi un moyen un peu de team
building cesser ses activités
nous avons tous un rôle à jouer c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui était inscrit au dos
de leur tee shirt et nous allons
justement parlé de team building et de
sport avec l'entretien de la semaine
c'est tout de suite
et je vous le disais tout à l'heure nous
sommes en plateau avec mes deux invités
vous êtes associé est à la tête de la
société touchdowns le sport devient de
plus en plus à la mode notamment en
entreprise pour fédérer une équipe re
motiver des salariés alors tout d'abord
monsieur vous êtes un peu les
spécialistes de ces de ce sport c'est
cet incentive
est-ce qu'on peut m'expliquer en quoi ça
consiste tout simplement à utiliser les
valeurs du sport
bah pour créer la cohésion les équipes
et ac et a aussi à mieux la performance
finalement des équipes puisque on s'est
rendu compte que étant sportif tous les
deux gutman de surcroît les valeurs le
collectif sont vraiment indispensables
pour faire avancer une équipe et donc
aussi comment faire passer de façon
ludique ces valeurs leur entreprise par
la présente justement de faire du sport
donc vous attachez vous proposer des
journées avec des activités sportives
pour les entreprises c'est ça pour des
grandes et petites entreprises comment
ça se déroule un petit peu alors
aujourd'hui nos clients sont plutôt des
rencontres des grosses ces entreprises
qui ont aujourd'hui encore des budgets
pour pour pas pour faire ce genre
d'activités maintenant j'en ai de la
journée type
enfin peut-être que sébastien pour un
petit on parle un petit peu ma journée
type saison des pluies de la formation
moi je ne peux plus du côté formation
touch iphone soit mis en place une
formation en management et dont nul
n'ose utilisant le tennis comme outil de
formation c'est c'est un travail nous
avons mis en place des ateliers
pédagogiques où les stagiaires pratique
du tennis
et face à ces ateliers pédagogiques ces
stagiaires sont face à des situations
problèmes et il faut réfléchir pour
essayer de trouver des solutions dans la
manière de coacher de manager de
communiquer avec son binôme et donc on
est sur le terrain et on essaie de faire
découvrir sa et une fois que tous ces
problèmes sont enfin toute cette
réflexion est mise en place ensuite à
les traiter en salle avec un
un formateur et on essaie de partir de
là pour pour continuer la formation
donc c'est transposer des difficultés
qu'on peut rencontrer dans reprise de
mon sport pour pouvoir mieux les gérer
ça
finalement oui c'est ce fait recette ce
pull c'est permettre aux gens de se
rendre compte de telles difficultés ou
de choses à améliorer de façon ludique
sans trop les truites brusque et
justement pour on est après d'améliorer
leurs compétences et leur performance en
entreprise donc on utilise vraiment le
sur le 121 de sport finalement on est on
est vrai on ne peut pas tricher en tout
cas voilà on tombe bien on fait un peu
tomber les masques et on est vrai et du
coup quand on proposait de la pratique
d'une activité sportive
tél maurice belay ce crime par exemple
ou en fait à venir aussi attribue des
internationaux comme astrid guyart qui
nous rend 5 mondial le fleuret féminin
ou tombale embarque aujourd'hui de
consultant numéro 1 sur canal+ de rugby
eh ben ça vraiment une valeur forte et
les gens sont impliqués là-dedans et du
coup après ce pas transpose un petit peu
leur leur vécu sur le monde après dans
l'entreprise en fait renvoyer après
seulement sur les images à vous proposer
justement de l'aviron vous me dites
orléans chris que c'était une idée qui
marchait très fort comment ça se passe
voilà brahms et une cinquantaine de
personnes qui vont les faire de l'aviron
commence assez pour l'aviron on peut en
pratique est alors l'intérêt
saint-herblain faire bien sûr à
plusieurs parce que ça se passe tout
seul aussi mais ça m'intéresse à pina
thérenty building on va dire à partir de
quatre personnes jusqu'à 100 personnes
par exemple on peut faire une journée
d'aviron où on est en bas taux de 4 ou 2
8 ça dépend un petit peu du nombre de
personnes qui y est on entre les ans
doit se débrouiller un petit peu tout
seul pour trouver la bonne façon
d'avancer ensemble parce que finalement
sur un bateau si chacun rames de son
côté on n'avancera pas c'est parce
qu'hier le plus fort qui va gagner c'est
l'équipage qui va ramer le plus ensemble
qui va gagner dans le canal de courcy a
pas de défi c'est vraiment les salariés
doivent avant sens où il ya une course
si mais finalement le challenge en fait
pour ça pour un peu mettre un peu de
pression mais l'idée c'est que les
salariés puissent trouver ensemble des
solutions pour avancer le mieux possible
donc ça va être la communication ça va
être de la du brainstorming pour trouver
maintien comme on peut faire pour
avancer sur la vire
sur l'aviron pourquoi nos rames sont
tamponnés voilà donc il faut il faut que
là dessus ils soient à l'écouté on
écoute l'un de l'autre pardon et qui
plus qu'une solution pour faire que leur
bateau avance et l'idée c'est après de
retranscrire ça dans mon entreprise
justement vont se rendre compte que bah
tout seul on n'est pas grand chose
finalement qu'une équipe n'avance mieux
et plus vite
sébastien blot par rapport voilà à aux
deux mondes que vous avez entreprise
pourquoi selon vous se tourne tel vers
le sport ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
possibilités d incentives gastronomiques
ou découvertes ou balade
pourquoi se diriger justement permet
d'activités sportives physique parce que
tous les employés finalement ne peuvent
peut-être pas aller faire un bar à
marthon ou à l'écart de l'alien oui
c'est sûr je crois que tout est un peu
dit c'est à dire que les gens de plus en
plus aime pratiquer le sport ça permet
d'être également dans des cadres
vraiment très sympathique
on parle de l'aviron quand on est au
bord de la mer afin de la rivière pardon
avec ce côté assez féerique c'est très
sympa donc il ya le plaisir de nos
centres plaisir de partager de pratiquer
mais voilà on a l'air libre et c'est
super sympa ensuite le niveau d'exigence
par rapport aussi au niveau des gens qui
sont en face de nous dire que des gens
qui sont très sportif on va tout à leur
demande et on va aller chercher un petit
peu justement dans les mettre un petit
peu dans l'eau y est allé chercher un
petit peu un effort supplémentaire parce
que les gens qui sont un peu plus en
difficulté bien on va les accompagner
sur un mouvement plus cool et plus plus
coulants pour que finalement que tout le
monde prenne plaisir que soit la
personne pas sportive à la personne très
sportif finalement vous avez fondé votre
société il ya trois ans vous avez
constaté une évolution par rapport
justement le sport par rapport à 7
finalement les incentives sportif c'est
un petit peu à l'américaine il ya
vraiment une évolution qui va avec le
monde du travail dans ces se bouge de là
on va dire oui depuis trois ans n'ont
pensé qu'à ceux ci bescond avant comment
ça peut se reconnaître mais pas que
le produit marche de mieux en mieux mais
ça il ya une évolution il ya une demande
aujourd'hui des tout cas de des gens des
prospects qui ont un contact de
pratiquer une activité sportive en plus
de leur réunion de travail où allah pour
essayer vraiment de faire passer le
message de cohésion parce qu'aujourd'hui
on est dans une société un peu plus
individualiste qu'avant et du coup ces
ateliers de cohésion de sport justement
collectif permettre vraiment d'amener
quelque chose alors salariée de
finalement le but de l'as entreprises
c'est quoi c'est d'augmenter la
performance est là de l'entreprise quoi
donc
donc chacun d'intérêt nous on a intérêt
parce que on proposera monde du sport
pour fédérer les salariés et
l'entreprise cherche elle a augmenté
c'est sa rentabilité finalement très
bien merci messieurs d'être venu sur
notre plateau pour nous parler justement
de cet incentive sportive et team
building
nous allons continuer maintenant avec le
chiffre de la semaine
cinq mille euros c'est notre chiffre la
semaine et ses galons le prix de
location de la tonte la plus chère dans
le village de l'âge comme open de france
de golf la moins chère se négocie tout
de même à 3000 euros 55 entreprises sont
présentes sur le village et plus de
52000 spectateurs vont s'y rendre dans
ces quatre jours et pour précisions
sachez que le panier moyen des dépenses
et tosa autour de 118 euros sur le
village et je vous propose maintenant de
passer à notre parti et magazines et
avec l'entrepreneur de la scène et cette
semaine nous nous intéressons pas un
mais à deux entrepreneurs yvelinois ils
sont déjà chef d'entreprise ce sont des
créateurs de la marque de vêtements de
sport okinawa qui fabrique les maillots
des joueurs du dessin animé culte olive
et tom en france avec leur société
tatouine il lance un nouveau concept le
snow ball ils nous l'ont présenté je
vous laisse le découvrir patrick jacques
de dixmude trois images et romain
respini au montage après le volley foot
le foot golf le futsal voici le site
vole une pratique hybride entre le
football et les bizarres lancée et conçu
par deux événements à la tête de la
société tatouine la balle blanche qui
reprend le ballon blanc donc le principe
c'est que sa table dans les ballons de
couleur pour rentrer dans les
différentes poches de la structure même
règle que billards deux joueurs
s'affrontent sur un terrain de 6 métros
sur 3 mètres 60
un concept né un peu par hasard plus
pour nous pour nous amuser on s'y tient
à se fabriquer une table de billard
football au départ plus pour se marrer
entre nous on s'est aperçu que pas mal
de gens d'y aller c'est une super bonne
idée c'est top on a fait une petite
vidéo et cette vidéo a explosé
complètement sur internet on a eu plus
de 10 millions de vues très rapidement
et donc on se dit qu'elle est sûrement
un
s'affaire derrière donc on a développé
tous les brevets on a déposé le concept
et le nom snowball diminutif du non
selon kirk est le grand billard anglais
l'aventuré a commencé il ya presque un
an la société livre sont produits depuis
le mois de janvier 2015 un peu partout
dans le monde
il faut compter entre 4000 et 6000 euros
pour son offrira une idée qui fonctionne
bien et les deux illinois n'en sont pas
à leur coup d'essai installé à
guyancourt
ils ont fondé en 2007 la ligne de
vêtements de sport au kawa celui là qui
est le maillot de la new team d'olivier
adam khel le maillot qu'on vend le plus
si vous ne connaissez pas au tibia
tonnes c'est un des personnage principal
du dessin animé culte des années 80
odile et m
tha olé
les deux amis idée de créer des
vêtements pour sponsoriser les équipes
présentes dans le manga si la marque
olive et tom est très demandé ce concept
n'avait jamais été proposé nous on
arrivait avec une philosophie
complètement différentes qui était de se
positionner comme un équipementier
sportif c'est qu'on n'a pas de tee shirt
reprenant la tête des personnages
par contre on a refait les maillots que
portent les joueurs dans le dessin animé
celui qui connaît olive et tom sans plus
identifiera peut-être pas le maillot de
telle ou telle équipe
par contre celle qui connaît très bien
olive et tom sera content de trouver le
maillot de la new team et non pas la
tête du personnage prix du maillot en
moyenne 30 euros
en huit ans ils sont passés de trois
modèles à 50 références proposées sur
leur site internet c'est par ce biais
que ce fonds une grande partie des
ventes 25 mille produits au kawa sont
vendus chaque année en france mais aussi
dans certains pays d'europe
les deux entrepreneurs ont dû acheter
non sans difficulté une licence
officielle pour rendre leurs vêtements
ils doivent impérativement rester très
proche de l'essence même du dessin animé
notre style guide qui est assez basique
un cas celui ci en fait ce look est le 1
le panini de l'époque sur lequel on
travaille pour dire voilà on va
reprendre ce type d'élément et on a une
charte graphique qui nous est fourni et
qu'on doit suivre en grande majorité par
les ayants droit
en fait qui reprend les différents
éléments qu'on a droit m'utiliser pour
la création
à l'origine les deux associés posséder
un magasin de vêtements à versailles si
le pari de la marque jaguar a fonctionné
il avait dès le début prévu de voir plus
grand
on l'a vraiment travaillé pour l'image
pour se faire plaisir pour rendre
hommage entre guillemets à la série et
pour s'en servir un peu comme d'un
marchepied
quand on parlait de la possibilité de
sponsoriser soit l'om sur le psg
on n'a évidemment pas du tout les moyens
de le faire mais l'objectif pour nous
avec olive et tom se donner une
crédibilité à notre marque une
visibilité à notre marque pour à terme
pouvoir sortir d'autres produits avec sa
marque au kawa la société tatouine
commercialise déjà des vêtements de
sport technique non estampillé olive et
tom
le textile hélas une activité
essentielle mais la diversité ne les
effraie pas il souhaite mettre l'accent
sur le football et voit déjà tout le
potentiel de ce nouveau sport qui n'a
pas encore de fédération les 2 heavy
noah lui prédisent le même avenir que le
foot en salle
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait être
complémentaire à l'activité du foot en
salle de 5,5
c'est vraiment la cible l'une des cibles
prioritaires mais on peut aussi voir ça
attendez
des hôtels dans des campings il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de secteurs d'activité
on peut on peut répondre et puis aussi
tout l'événementiel tout ce qui va être
une scéne tive auprès d'une société un
cee collectivités locales une trentaine
de ce football ont déjà été vendus les
carnets de commandes sont pleins
un concept qui pourrait profiter d'un
bon coup de projecteur grâce à l'euro
2016 et je vous propose maintenant de
découvrir à l'entreprise de la semaine à
cette suite
et par cette canicule je vous propose
une petite pause fraîcheur la société
altarès spécialisée dans les glaces
s'est installé à trappes en juillet 2011
aujourd'hui elle emploie 8 personnes et
produit 100 litres par jour en été nous
sommes aller la visiter et voir dans les
coulisses comment se fabrique et les
classes williams elle est nickel et demi
d'euros une fois que cette glace est à
la bonne température
alex traite airs préférés dans le
récipient lui convient paul maman le
gérant de l'entreprise de glace alter
elle cette société a été créée en 2005 à
paris avant de prendre ses quartiers à
trappes en juillet 2011 cet ancien
restaurateur n'a pas hésité à tout
plaquer pour se lancer dans ce projet le
dating j'avais il ya très très longtemps
il ya une
une trentaine d'années quand j'ai
commencé dans la restauration où je
faisais mes glaces et
bon j'ai toujours aimé faire ça et ce
qui fait que j'ai voulu en faire mon
métier à plein temps
chose que je fais depuis 2005 ce que je
regrette oui c'est de ne pas avoir
commencé ce métier beaucoup plus tôt
parce que c'est un
un métier qui permet de dormir chez soi
tous les soirs et d'avoir ce week end et
jours fériés que c'est appréciable
aujourd'hui le glacier est à la tête
d'une équipe de 8 personnes l'année
dernière son chiffre d'affaires a
dépassé les 500 mille euros
une réussite qui n'est pas en grande
partie des conditions climatiques
c'est un métier qui est imprévisible
globalement sur une année complète
vous pourrez avoir des années plus ou
moins pourri où vous aurez l'année
dernière où le mois de juin était a été
a été mauvais mais bon ça sera rattrapé
par un mois de septembre qui sera
meilleure ou par un mois de février qui
peut être très bon alors que le mois de
février est traditionnement très froid
c'est un métier qui vous oblige
simplement d'avoir une confiance absolue
la dame nature
le pot de glace elle perd elle est
vendue entre 2 euros 67 euros 50 en
fonction de sa taille pour se démarquer
dans un marché ultra concurrentiel et se
frotter aux plus grandes entreprises
internationales
la société chinoise a opté pour une
recette artisanale
on se démarque fondamentalement par la
qualité et par là le pourcentage de
matière que l'on à l'intérieur
concrètement vous avez 1 70% de manga
l'intérieur du
amateur de la glace le reste est composé
d'un sirop qui est composé le sucre et
d'eau riendeau caramel beurre salé fleur
d'oranger votre cas citrons les parfums
alter elles séduisent les restaurateurs
et les magasins français et produits
s'exporte également delà de l'hexagone
là vous avez une palette qui va par des
palettes qui vont partir pour le canada
tout prêtre
vva
ça va montréal 500 litres de glaces sont
produits dans l'entreprise
elle perd elle quotidiennement pendant
l'été un chiffre qui pourrait exposer
avec les températures caniculaires
enregistrées ces derniers jours et ça
donne envie
c'est bientôt la fin de notre émission
avant de quitter je vous propose de
regarder la journée à la semaine
et pour la semaine prochaine il y a deux
rendez vous à ne pas manquer si vous
êtes intéressé par le statut d'auto
entrepreneur la maison de l'entreprise
organise le mercredi 8 juillet un
atelier sur ce thème de 10h à 12h vous
retrouvez toutes les informations sur ce
statut qui peut parfois sembler un petit
peu compliqué enfin le 9 juillet la cité
des métiers propose une réunion
d'information sur les métiers et les
formations dispensées à l'afpa
l'association nationale pour la
formation des adultes qui existe depuis
60 ans le rendez vous est fixé de 10
heures à midi il faut s'inscrire plus
d'informations sur le site internet de
la cité des métiers
c'est la fin de notre émission je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis je veux je
vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de fil
ico le dernier de cette saison je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée